ici on a une souche qui fait au moins 2
mètres de diamètre mais à d'autres
endroits de la de l'île de vancouver on
peut en trouver des deux fois voire
trois fois plus grande ça veut dire si m
de diamètre c'est pour montrer à quel
point ce sont des arbres extrêmement
âgés qui ont été coupées
[Musique]
je sais pas si vous me voyez lâché à
gauche de l'arve tout en bas on est ici
dans une coupe à blanc qui a commencé à
repousser parce qu'elles datent d'il ya
sept ou huit ans et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que la compagnie
forestière a laissé un douglas un
douglas un arbre de 66 mètres de haut de
4 mètres de diamètre c'était le plus
gros en fait qui se trouvait ici et ça
permet de voir la grandeur l'importance
que ces arbres avaient à l'époque dans
cette zone là certains arbres de l'île
de vancouver ont plus de 1000 en c de
véritables témoins du passé et la forêt
pluviale tempérer cette une de celles
qui capte le plus le carbone les
coupables ont comme ceux là on les
retrouve souvent très très loin des
villes donc c'est pas toujours facile
d'avoir conscience de leur présence il
faut rouler plusieurs heures dans la
forêt ici pour pouvoir voir ses immenses
zones forestières qui on a disparu
anvers sont les forêts anciennes qui
commencent à être coupés à la fin du 19e
siècle en jaune on voit les secteurs
coupé puis replantés avec de plus petits
arbres
[Musique]
la forêt ancienne a presque disparu et
en rose c'est la forêt de deuxième
génération les repousses d'arbres de
moins 100 ans qui se font à leur tour
coupé 93% nos arbres exporté ventes en
asie depuis 2009 les exportations de
billes de bois vers le japon presque
doublé celles vers la chine ont été
multipliées par dix
il faut préciser que couper ces arbres
c'est légal l'industrie a tout à fait le
droit
les compagnies forestières rappelle au
passage que l'exportation génère des
milliards de dollars et même si l'emploi
est en baisse elle donne encore du
travail des dizaines de milliers de
canadiens